foreign
[Music]
Singapore hope you're all doing well
firstly I like to congratulate on the
series I've seen their first two
episodes and it's incredible I'm really
excited for fans to see it but can we
start with like can you talk about the
immense pleasure of creating a new take
on a lot of the Rings
yeah it's been a pretty
um pretty cool experience
um
we are being able to adapt a new age is
pretty exciting and bring a new age to
life and bring things like new Menor and
a whole new time period uh as uh it's a
very special thing yeah
yeah it's um it's a great privilege to
be a part of Middle Earth and um it's
it's just so exciting to
to bring Middle Earth back to screen
um you know and I I really hope the fans
are excited just as excited as I am
because it's going to be special and um
I really hope everyone enjoys it were
you guys big fans at all before joining
the series
yeah I was I was definitely a big Lord
of the Rings fan
um I knew I'd watch the films I'd never
actually read the books I'd never read
The Hobbit um and I played of the
PlayStation games and then when I sat
down to prepare I read as much as I
could yeah so
um I'm a much bigger fan now having been
involved in this show
um growing up not really it's not sort
of my generation so um I I knew of a lot
of the Rings I knew that it was it was a
massive
um thing and
um I knew that there was Gollum and I
knew Frodo lost his finger
um but
um obviously after I got the role I I
sat down and I did the dive and watched
the films and I read the whole bed and
you know
um got into got into the world so yeah
thank you Charlie Halpern is a
completely new character for the series
how would you describe him and what made
him what made you want to take the role
um well I wanted to take the role
because it was involved in this universe
I didn't really know anything about
halbrand when I was auditioning such was
the tight security around the
information
and he's a uh he's a man he's from the
south
that's a good start
and he is starting a new life I think
he's leaving his path behind him and he
is ready to begin Anew and he meets
characters which illuminate things in
his past things in his future and make
him question his decisions I think yeah
yeah and I think that said character has
to be Galadriel
um I feel like refers me
um that scene seems like a really major
pivotal role not just for your character
but for the series as well so could you
share about their relationship and how
it evolves throughout the series yeah I
mean I don't want to say too much
because it it takes a lot of twists and
turns as the series goes on um but what
I think I can say is that
he's made some decisions in his past and
um which have taken him to this point
and she
makes him I think question a few things
about his past and I think same him to
her and there's kind of a push and a
pull in their relationship in that he
will move One Direction and she'll pull
him back and vice versa and it's
interesting to watch that play out
throughout the series yeah yeah in
tyrotio is a clear example of how
history and War affects people even
Generations after it's happened
um so what's in store for Theo not that
it seems that any of the war is
approaching
oh
um I think I think Theo is is very very
curious I think he feels that his people
don't deserve how they're being treated
um
obviously you know they don't live in
the in the greatest of conditions and
the elves don't treat them very well
um and I think you know with with the
history of the people there are
trickles of that you know trickles of of
our history of men still within the
village and
um there's a lot of a lot of questions
and I think Theo is is always searching
for answers and by searching for those
answers I think he he finds himself in
some situations
[Music]
foreign